اكد كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين وانجيا
على ان الصين تثمن رغبه روسيا في تسويه
الصراع مع اوكرانيا سلميا مؤكدا ستلعب
دورا في تسويه الصراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وستكون موضوعيه وعلى الحياد فيما يتعلق
بالازمه الاوكرانيه في المقابل وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه اكدت انها اطلعت على خطه
بكين ولم تناقش تفاصيلها مشيره الى ان
وجهات النظر بشكل القضايا الدوليه بين
بكين وموسكو متطابقه الى حد كبير اشارت
موسكو الى تقديرها لموقف الصين بشان قضيه
اوكرانيا ووصفته بالمتوازنه
العلاقات الدوليه اليوم اكثر صعوبه لم
تتحسن بعد انهيار النظام ثنائي القطب بل
على العكس اصبحت اكثر حده في هذا الصدد
يلعب التعامل على الساحه الدوليه بين
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه والاتحاد الروسي
كما اكدنا مرارا وتكرارا دورا مهما في
استقرار الوضع الدولي بالطبع نحن ننتظر من
رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه ان يقوم
بزياره لروسيا اتفقنا على ذلك في وقت سابق